vous arrive-t-il d’abandonner votre
panier quand vous magasinez en ligne
vous n'êtes pas les seuls sur 10
consommateurs 7 vont quitter la page
sans procéder à l'achat et souvent c'est
parce qu'ils doivent encore créer un
nouveau compte ou encore réinitialiser
un mot de passe oublié alors les géants
du web ont proposé une solution vous
servir de votre identifiant Google Apple
ou Facebook par exemple pour vous
connecter sur le site du commerçant
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'authentification unique sautez l'étape
du énième mot de passe c'est plus
pratique et ça vous convaincra peut-être
de vous rendre à la caisse au grand
bonheur du commerçant bref tout le monde
est gagnant sauf que vous devez savoir
une chose en vous connectant avec votre
identifiant Facebook par exemple vous
lui permettez de suivre toutes vos
activités et de cataloguer l'information
même lorsque vous n'êtes plus connecté à
sa plateforme bref vous alimentez la
bête sans parler du commerçant qui lui
aurait accès à vos données photos
adresse courriel numéro de téléphone en
plus de tout ce que vous publiez en mode
public si cela vous inquiète optez pour
un gestionnaire de mot de passe qui les
conservera en mémoire à votre place ce
n'est pas parfait mais c'est plus
discret passer le mot
[Musique]